Democrats believe they have to lash out
in anger in order to win in 2018 if they
do win they'll double down on that anger
hoping it carries them to victory in
2020 did you like those mobs invading
the Senate and the steps of the Supreme
Court are you enjoying top Democratic
officials nodding and smiling at crowds
harassing Republicans and restaurants
get ready for much much more the only
way to shut down the Democrats new mob
rule strategy is to stop them called at
the ballot box in 2016 Hillary Clinton
lost the presidency because Democrats
didn't show up to vote they simply
assumed she'd sweep to victory they were
wrong today Republicans feel optimistic
after the confirmation of Brett
Kavanaugh which is understandable I do
too but that optimism should not blind
us to the importance of voting on
November 6th this Democratic Party is
more radical than ever they've embraced
a nastier vision of politics than ever
but that does not mean they are fated to
lose your vote matters your vote counts
get out there on Election Day and ensure
that the Democratic Party of Nancy
Pelosi and Chuck Schumer and Hillary
Clinton aren't allowed anywhere near the
levers of power